je crois qu'il est là la bêtise
bonjour stromayer bon la communauté
présente à la communauté présente et
bien bonjour tout le monde comment allez
vous
[Musique]
et
hop et ben écoute
ça demandait comment il allait bah ouais
vous allez bien ouais c'est vrai que je
suis pas habituée en liga à faire des
live donc
bonjour à tous bon jour à tout
merci d'être si nombreux
fringué comme ce matin oui tout à fait
les faibles observation tout à faire
j'étais à la radio ce matin
à temps écrit qui veut passer un live
ensemble dans sa vague brit possible n'a
pas le temps pour ça non désolé
puissions commencer qu est né là bas
mais par exemple alors voilà les tissus
on est le roi de belgique au caire il ya
beaucoup de questions sur tes concerts
est réellement
alors hop on peut commencer
tranquillement comme agression alors non
si simon 23 met fin aux débats randy
stromae ou stromae et ben moi je dis
stromae mais franchement faites comme
vous voulez hein les gars y'a pas c'est
chacun le dit à sa façon il n'y a pas de
règle donc est ce qu'il y aura des
concerts à bercy j'ai vu ah
ben
ouais je pense bien je pense bien qu'il
ya des concerts qui sont prévues à bercy
mais ça s'appelle plus bercy d'ailleurs
s'appelle accords hôtel arena et il ya
un concert qui est prévue le 24 mars
février dans pas très longtemps et
d'ailleurs en fait c'est conserva ils
sont faits en en
exclusivité donc c'est à dire que je
vais présenter certains des morceaux de
demont
du prochain album et donc c'est à dire
que le public découvrira des nouveaux
morceaux là en live j'avoue que je n'ai
jamais fait ça enfin si peut-être avec
un morceau vite fait mais là l'agent je
vais en faire quand même 4 5 et
évidemment les morceaux les plus connus
ça c'est inévitable donc donc voilà
bonjour le canada
alors pourquoi jeanne acte jeanne avec
des deux corps partout pourquoi
multitude comme choix de titre de nouvel
album à bien en fait mon frère m'avait
dit dont confrères qui est aussi mon
directeur créatif m'avait dit ouais en
fait je trouve que tu fais boffin une de
tes caractéristique c'est que tu fais
toujours des personnages dans tes
chansons
est alors une chose qui était sûr c'est
qu'on voulait
notifié le fait qu' il y avait beaucoup
d'influencés diverses du monde entier
sur cet album musicalement et donc
finalement en alliant textes et mes et
musique je trouve une multitude était
assez représentatif de cet album donc
donc voir son service quota de le jouer
du courant contraire devant tout le
monde bien sûr mais en même temps j'ai
un peu chez un peu stressé
quand même parce que j'ai jamais fait ce
à quoi j'ai chanté devant une foule qui
te regarde et qui est là ok et donc à la
fin du morceau c'est ouais c'est c'est
eh bien c'était moyen tu vois je sais
pas et puis et en me demandant si vont
commencer à chanter le refrain ou pas
faim tu vois je me levais chum interroge
à chaque fois que je la chante quoi en
vrai l'âge exemple la question ça qu'il
veut faire quels morceaux préférés de
toi là beaucoup qui sur les os les deux
dernières n'a pas mal an ouais ouais non
non je suis confiant pourtant mais la
santé et l'enfer va écouter
alors julio le chat roux
à
trèbes au très bon pseudo nîmes déjà
comment t'es venue l'idée de faire
l'enfer
ben franchement j'étais chez moi à la
maison l'époque que j'avais encore un
gros mot studio parce qu'après j'ai
décidé de faire un vrai studio dans un
vrai bureau maintenant on a des vrais
bureaux chez mosshart et donc tout ça
pour dire que je bats voilà j'ai
commencé à l'écrire je crois que le
premier truc qui me sont venues ces les
accords au piano et puis je voulais
rajouter d'un truc qui ressemblait un
peu à des des voix vu le bulgare est
donc j'ai commencé à les imiter et puis
après j'ai contacté orenda elle
s'appelle c'est un trio
de choeur bulgare qui vit à paris et
elles m'ont aidée en fait à chanter en
plus sur ce morceau est en fait quand je
le composaient y avait ma femme qui
était juste derrière la porte et elle
était assez enfin m'indique été touchés
parce que c'était là un peu comme si
c'était le premier morceau
potable en fait qui sortait de mes
doigts et de mai et de ma tête et elle
était quand même assez touchés étaient
contents que je sois un peu de retours
quoi voilà je sais sur des réponses plus
courtes peut-être non comme tu le sens
écoute serait inspiré pour contre reste
au frais
alors trop hâte de voir aux vieilles
charrues bah ouais moi aussi j'ai trop
hâte d'y être aussi charrues trop bien
alors minimoys 13 pourquoi une si longue
absence ouais alors pourquoi une si
longue absence
parce qu'en fait j'avais j'avais
beaucoup bossé j'avais beaucoup tourné
j'ai fait 210 concerts en deux ans c'est
à dire un concert tous les trois jours
donc en fait c'était vraiment beaucoup
et donc j'avais simplement feint même si
j'avais pas fait autant de concerts ça
s'arrêtait toute façon fin 2015 et puis
après j'ai eu des petits princes de
santé évidemment qui m'ont rappelée à
l'ordre mais j'avais juste besoin de
vivre des choses quoi donc je me suis
marié j'ai eu un enfant
j'ai bossé aussi je pense que t'en as
parlé tout à l'heure mais j'ai bossé
avec d'autres artistes gerbi yelich pour
un clip pour des clips j'ai bossé pour
des clips pour de la musique
pas tout seul évidemment je fais ça avec
mon frère et avec ma femme et puis on a
fait des collections aussi avec la
marque de vêtements qu'on a lancées
ensemble
j'ai posé ma voix sur certains morceaux
c'est vrai mais en fait le morceau d'os
qui parlait de marseille qu'orelsan la
pluie en fait mort soit il était déjà
fait depuis racine carrée fin déjà fait
en tout cas ma partie était déjà fait
que des racines carrées et lui a écrit
ces couples et après en fait que c'est
comment ces revues bah tu vois tu te
souviens tu avais fait un truc est tout
gamin il m'a reparlé de la pluie je fais
juste morceau j'avais déjà oublié ben je
vais écouter et puis là il a commencé à
écrire dessus quoi moi j'avais essayé
d'écrire dessus mais en fait il était
nul mon morceau et lui c'était vraiment
mieux quoi
c'est bien la collaboration des fonds
alors ouais ouais ça aide mais est
pareil pour défiler part défier tu l'as
vécu ce moment pour le défilé des filets
je l'avais vraiment écrite pour pour
défiler voit tout à fait ce que les
différentes histoires en plus dans la ça
c'est ouais ouais c'était un morceau de
9 minutes et j'ai pris un simple sur
splice en fait tout simplement je suis
pas été chercher très loin et et puis
j'ai commencé à fermont instrus et et je
me suis dit tiens je gardais le même
semble pendant les tout le temps et
voilà quoi ok
la prochaine question
prochaine question acte terrine gap
que penses tu des autres artistes
bruxellois comme dame saut et angèle bas
je les aime bien
angèle je crois que mon morceau préféré
de son dernier album c c'est libre je
crois
et le morceau qu'ils ont fait ensemble
il est cool aussi
bah ouais je les aime bien franchement
je les aime bien la scène musicale au
mérite
bah ouais ouais ouais ouais puis à des
artistes ferment aussi genre touristes
le m6
ah ouais il ya beaucoup d'artistes et
s'écoulent et puis on a toujours eu en
fait y en a toujours eu mais c'est vrai
que il ya à l'époque on avait en tout
cas à l'époque que je débutais y avait
un truc où on croyait pas beaucoup à la
musique locale en belgique
mais mais voilà après il faut essayer
quoi exactement mettre d'accord
alors adams au cul à élèves
ces dames chose à
auby ouais je pense aussi est ce qu'il y
aura des fuites sur l'album bon ben je
sais pas si je peux répondre à cette
question mais faut en fait y en a pas
mais en fait il ya tellement de
deux trajets tellement travaillé avec
d'autres compositeurs de musiciens et
tout ça qu'en fait c'est un peu comme
des feat même si à mon nom qui apparaît
dans les crédits la liste est longue
quoi il ya même le leur caisse nationale
de belgique qui a collaboré à bosser
dessus avec les arrangements de bruno
letort yauch ndala le lecteur bulgare
gaughan un jour des rues une espèce de
violon chinois
qu'est ce qu'il y avait un jour donné un
qui s'appelle selman qui joue de
l'acquis jus de ces une flûte turque un
jour de charango bolivien qui s'appelle
alfredo coca
mon frère aussi qui a fait des prod
dessus luc junior vu que junior vingt
neuf heures
et puis qui avait encore j'avais envie
de citer
oubliée ouais et alors moon willis aussi
un producteur anglais qui avait très
vite compris la direction que je voulais
prendre et qui adore faire des
recherches sur le groupe parce que moi
c'est quelque chose qui m'obsède
beaucoup c'est vraiment le groove c'est
vraiment aller chercher des rythmiques
qui nous qui nous perturbent et qu'ils
nous fassent est ce qu'on ressent un peu
dans santé et je me suis inspiré d'un
gars qui s'appelle dj alex et de la
musique comme biao ci de là et de la
halle et de la combi électronique
d'ailleurs de mexique j'ai vu qu'il ya
des gens du mexique aussi
beaucoup mexicain va t'en mieux merci
les gars et donc voilà quoi donc j'adore
les différents groupes cette question
est brûlante
alors vas louve est ce qu une tournée
est prévue si oui où mais je pense que
les dates elles sont annoncées mais j'ai
en fait j'ai peur de dire des conneries
parce que je sais pas lesquels sont
annoncés et lesquelles ne sont pas mais
je pense qu'il ya déjà beaucoup de noms
mais en fait ici parce que j'ai vu les
remplissages donc si si elles sont déjà
annoncés
franchement je passe un peu partout
je sais que je passe à nantes et je
pense que c'est même déjà complet à
nantes si je me trompe pas
je pense partout en france je pense pas
en belgique en suisse
le québec je crois que c'est pas encore
annoncé et il y aura une tournée aux
etats-unis aussi il ya coachella qui est
déjà annoncé
donc voilà quoi
quel est mon sang préféré de moi même
quel est mon préféré de moi même
c'est un morceau vous connaissez pas
donc en fait ils veulent sortir
non jeu désolé je peux redire les
premières se connaissent la saf est
contraint d'être l'un des seuls artistes
francophones des beiges la lettre des
traditionnels
ben ça fait plaisir franchement ça fait
plaisir surtout que surtout que
franchement c'était pas gagné d'avancé
dans la mesure où techniquement c'est un
peu compliqué de nous accueillir
pour vous la faire courte en fait on est
on va enfin sur la scène donc on
travaille avec des mecs qui font de la
cide j'irai donc ces genres d animation
style pixar et dreamworks et tout
donc avec une boîte qui s'appelle nfc
une boîte belge et alors on travaille
aussi avec des bras robotisés comme
comme ce convoi dans l'est dans les
usines de voitures donc y aura 10 bras
comme ça qu'ils portent chacun un écran
et ensemble ils format géant écran et
donc donc ça s'appelle super lourd et
donc techniquement ce n'était pas gagné
d'avancé pour pour coachella et est donc
donc voilà finalement ouais ils nous ont
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a été
accueillie sur une certaine scène et
tout est d'être headliner parce qu'en
fait c'est comme ça que
je suis considéré et donc ça fait
vraiment super plaisir quoi vraiment
chez moi si je pouvais parler du live
serait au tac au tac d'état c'est très
intéressant c'est trop tard cette fois
sont
du coup prochaine question alors ouais
quel est mon groupe de musique préféré
un groupe à
j'hésite entre genre et un truc genre
muse ou où les autres là comment il
s'appelle
aller les trois rappeurs américains
d'amigo ce pur et sain brève n'est plus
dans quoi un truc genre muse ou migros
non mais je crois quand même me go ça
passe avant ce que je connais et
j'écoute pas beaucoup de groupes en fait
est un musicien du coup voilà un
musicien moi je suis fan de adel
vraiment très très fan d'adele
est ce qu'il ya des fans d'abel ici me
gausse ouais je vois que
ouais ouais
alors comment t'es venue l'idée de te
lancer dans la musique de fanta retisse
tu points world
comment je me bats en fait
c'est juste que j'ai commencé je me suis
jamais vraiment dit à un moment que
j'allais arrêter quoi c'est surtout ça
qui s'est passé et que ça se profile
professionnaliser au fur et à mesure
jusqu'à devenir un vrai métier quoi
aujourd'hui enfin pour l'album que j'ai
fait là j'ai fait vraiment du neuf 17
tous les jours j'avais déposé mon fils
puis j'allais être recherchée à la fin
de la journée comme un métier normal et
et voilà quoi donc donc c'est devenu un
vrai métier pour rebondir derrière ce
que tu sais qu utiliser sur l on a des
femmes d'alger la contrainte ah bah
ouais mais qui est en soin d'elle en
même temps exactement et tu ne vois
comme ça
prochaine question du coup il me semble
que c'est corinne
corinne attend ici un ajax et wind ou du
texte sont bien écrits je trouve qu'elle
est ton secret merci beaucoup
c'est marrant parce qu'il m'a fallu du
temps avant d'accepter ce compliment
genre je mettais pas mes textes j'ai
imprimé pas mes textes dans les livrets
de mes albums parce que parce que je
trouvais que ça voulait dire qu'en gros
j'étais ultra fier de mes textes et donc
je ne faisais pas et après je me suis
rendu compte que ça a aidé simplement
les gens à pouvoir comprendre les textes
donc j'ai donc pour le prochain jeu les
faits
et je suis plus à l'aise avec le fait
que j'écris pas si mal mais en fait
c'est peut-être parce que c'est pas trés
choix de décrire fin pour montre que
c'est un grand place est pas vraiment un
plaisir
on t'écoutera n'a pas eu cette
impression mais ben merci beaucoup mais
c'est peut-être peut-être parce que je
me casse trop la tête ou je sais pas
mais en même temps je crois que j'ai
comparé ma façon d'écrire avec cette
d'orelsan parce que souvent quand j'y
pense quand je blogue sur mes textes je
l'appelle en fait et c'est ce que j'ai
fait pour multitude et en fait il est il
est venu et il m'a montré la façon dont
il écrivait et franchement c'est
vraiment impressionnant fa lui il va
vraiment loin quoi c'est à dire que en
fait au mieux on comparer nos façons un
travail de travailler à angèle lui moi
et j'en ris me disais ouais quand il a
bossé avec angers danger d'utiliser bah
voila moi quand j'écris je commence à
écrire quoi voilà c'est tout premier
premier première fois ce deuxième phase
rim voit là et puis c'est tout quoi et
lui genre orelsan genre et fait des
notes interminable mais genre et il va
chercher hyper loin à quoi tu vois le
genre moi je cherche aussi mais mais
franchement enfin je suis vite avec mon
dico des synonymes émond et mon dico
dream tu vois vite fait sur le côté et
puis enfin mais comme toi à vincennes
elle est vachement cool par la provence
et de voir le texte parce qu'il est
super bon et il se voit l'asie en même
temps je pense que c'est normal y'a pas
de secret pour avoir des textes aussi
bon que lui il n'y a pas de secret il
faut bosser il faut bosser comme un
acharné c'est ce qui fait donc voilà
ça va dit ouais
non il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent tu
es formidable du coup ça résonne avec
ton titre tout à fait formidable
quelles sont les plus grandes stars que
j'ai rencontré je crois que la plus
grande ce témoin donne à
tulle a rencontré où j'ai rencontré deux
fois une fois à londres et et puis une
deuxième fois à new york
ouais c'est impressionnant ben ouais
quand même c'est quand même
du coup tu peux enchaîner avec ea les
questions qu'on a sélectionné
as-tu qu'on corinne colin as-tu
conscience de l'impact que ta musique de
kata musique sur les gens perso elle m'a
aidée à des moments où je n'allais pas
bien je t'adore écoute c'est très gentil
j'en ai pas toujours conscience mais
c'est vrai que souvent j'ai des retours
de jean est et sur l'enfer par exemple
m'a fait des super beau retour des gens
qui me disent voilà ça me fait du bien
de mettre des mots en fête sur des
choses qui des sujets qui sont parfois
tabous et et voilà c'est vrai que j'ai
tendance à parler de choses
dont on sait enfin dont on parlerait pas
forcément sur sur des musiques un peu
entraînante et voilà c'est un truc que
j'aime faire
voilà
alors qu'amy la milk comment tu te
prépares avant de monter sur scène
ben là je viens de faire une nouvelle
routine
avec une coach vocal donc c'est à dire
que je pense à je vais essayer de faire
genre deux heures avant de manger après
une heure une heure et demie avant faire
un peu de corde à sauter ou un peu de
sport
après fermé échauffement vocaux et puis
après j'aime bien ce outils en l'air
pour pas me faire un claquage quand même
mais ça c'est en théorie mais je sais
pas si je vais réussir à faire surtout
la corde à sauter là avant de monter sur
scène je suis pas sûr mais j'ai vu un
docu sur jamel un jour qui nous fait
chier plus telle qu'elle est en fait en
gros il disait qu'il avait fait il
faisait du sport il avait fait une fois
du sport avant de monter sur scène et
qui si l'avant deux fois plus d'énergie
quoi et des jeunes enfants qui peut-être
et donc je me demande si j'essayerai pas
de faire ça
un jour parce que apparemment c'est
vraiment une bonne solution pour
essayer je vais laisser
alors mieux 64 tu joues quel instrument
franchement moi c'est surtout les
percussions donc moi j'ai appris la
batterie je mets de monter qu'il ya
moins de taper sur un truc toute façon
ça j'avoue que je me débrouille pas mal
et puis un peu de claviers quoi mais
sincèrement je sais pas si j'ai pas
j'arrive à être
indépendante mais demain donc
donc ça ça va pour moi mais en fait mais
par contre les doigts c'est vraiment
compliqué donc en général je fais main
gauche main droite mais j'arrive pas
vraiment être indépendant des doigts
comme un vrai clavier risque donc je me
considère pas comme un vrai claviériste
je plaque des accords wii est vite fait
mais ce qu'on peut se demander là
prévient bien derrière mais je vais très
très nuit là donc les gars mes parents
vivent mieux pas essayé mais géré par
exemple un exemple de piano de
formidable
je me souviens plus des accords dont je
pourrais même plus vous de jouer j'ai
juste le tdu ding ding ding donc j'ai
joué comme ça oui ça évidemment même sur
les limites avec deux doigts je les
jouais je les enregistrer et après j'ai
plaqué les accords derrière et donc donc
voilà il ya quelqu'un qu'ils vendent sur
le lac
tout le monde des idées pour l'équipe
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure un ami
idées pour les clips mais en fait déjà
c'est pas toujours mes idées
en fait
donc la façon dont on travaille avec eux
c'est avec eux mais deux directeurs
créatifs c'est ma femme coralie barbie
qui est aussi ma styliste et mon frère
dont je parlais tout à l'heure lui que
j'ignore 29 eur est en fait un
brainstorm à 3 en fait
et c'est vrai que souvent ça pose des
fois peut-être un peu des problèmes avec
des real il ya des céréales qui
comprennent comme le real de tous les
mêmes et
de gaffes de billy de doha nie pas et et
de hostage de billy halliche et de mon
prochain clip qui s'appelle henry
schofield et en fait lui on vient avec
un concept on lui explique donc il ya
toute une narration par exemple pour le
prochain clip c'est vraiment une idée de
ma femme je vais enfin vrai ce n'est pas
un bon exemple ce que je pourrais pas en
parler mais
pour l'enfer bon c'était pas un concept
très très compliqué mais là c'est vrai
que c'est moi qui voulais avoir un truc
très simple parce que c'est vrai qu'on
m'attend toujours avec des choses un peu
surprenante et tout ça est des fois en
fait je me suis dit non mais en fait il
faut faire un truc ultra simple parce
que on peut surprendre aussi par la
simplicité et donc on s'est dit ce
serait un plan séquence et avec les
effet d'accélérer de ralenti tout ça
dans le même plan séquence mais en
général on brainstorm à 3 le clip de
santé par exemple c'était une idée mon
frère qui voulait cette histoire de deux
modes d'emploi d'apprendre à danser tout
ça et est donc tout ce qui dévie venait
de lui le prochain clip c'est l'idée de
ma femme est en fait voilà après on
réfléchit ensemble à creuser un peu plus
parce qu'il sait un clip c'est pas
qu'une idée c'est une narration et et
puis après on les expose à un réal il
faut trouver le real qui a envie de le
faire et et puis surtout qui a qui m'est
assez son ego de côté pour se dire en
face par l'historien pas de moi et
finalement j'exécute enfin j'exécute pas
mais mon espace de création de kayes
restreint et donc donc voilà des fois ça
se passe bien des fois ça se passe un
peu moins bien mais c'est comme ça qu'on
procède
ma plus grande fierté musicale
musicale
donc donc
[Musique]
c'est pas des archives man quoi c'est
genre musical quoi musicale ouais ouais
ouais t'as ta propre interprétation en
réalité inclus quand on dit ça
le trick sais pas je sais pas peut-être
que c'était la composition de papa ou
tel parce que c'était pas hyper simple
je me suis un peu dépassé dans la mesure
où ce n'était pas juste quatre accords
et une boucle de quatre mesures quoi
donc par un succès aussi reçu
non au delà de ça vraiment purement la
réussite juste personnelle d'avoir
réussi à composer un truc un peu
compliqué et je truc que j'avais jamais
dit je pense mais en fait c'est que je
me suis un fort inspiré de la
ritournelle de sébastien tellier
pourquoi pas où tu es en fait
et en fait c'est vrai que quand tu vois
ça fait pareil en fait c'est là les
basses les bases qui te font deux notes
et puis et puis tu plat qu'un accord est
donc je me suis inspiré de la même
rythmique et et voilà j'étais assez fier
parce que c'était une composition un peu
plus longue que juste quatre mesures qui
seraient peut être quoi mais voilà
j'essaie de voir quand même
ça va vite quand même hein ah bah oui
parce qu'ils sont 6000
ils sont six mille hockey un feat avec
orelsan mais pourquoi pas être plaisir
mais là moi j'ai fini l'album lula fini
le sien donc je pense qu'on est plutôt
en phase mais en face de tourner la bêta
mais mauvais timing
[Musique]
et puis surtout d'être naturel quoi
parce qu'en fait on était en studio pour
son album on est en sus tient au studio
pour mon alpha wann dernier album
d'orelsan mais je suis là son album
d'avant et après mon album aussi est en
fait finalement ça vient pâture est donc
faux que l'envi soin mutuel au bon
moment et puis que ça fasse sens par
rapport à la thématique de l'album est
tout
quel endroit solides en belgique tu
aimerais faire découvrir
quels endroits insolites j'aimerais
faire découvrir en belgique à bruxelles
là bas il ya le point de vue des sept
meuse en fait moi j'étais à l'internât
dans un
dans un bled qu'on appelle goddyn
dans le sud de namur à 20 minutes de
namur donc c'est une ville qui dans le
sud de bruxelles est en fait il ya un
endroit où tu peux faire du parapente et
donc c'est on appelle ça peut inviter
cette semaine on appelle ça le point de
vue des sept mu parce que tu vois cette
fois la meuse donc c'est un cours d'eau
à l'aise et donc tu la vois cette fois
parce que c'est un c'est en haut d'une
colline et donc voilà donc c'est un
endroit que j'apprécie le dise le thème
était un as loupé ils ont pour rebondir
par rapport à décembre à bosser il y en
a dans les questions de carrière après
ouais on te demande ton snack où tu as
friterie préféré à bruxelles
bah celui la friterie à laquelle j'ai
tout le temps c'est la friterie de la
barrière donc la barrière de saint
gilles en fait et
cd je sais pas l'origine des ces deux
des femmes qui font les frites je sais
qu'ils sont de l'est mais je sais pas
d'où et j'avoue que
en plus j'ai mangé mon petit enfin bref
elles me font je dois pas faire la file
et touffah bref j'ai mes petits normale
du même petit avantage normal et donc
j'ai souvent là on se prend la petite
frite souvent un format de prendre un
petit bikini moi je prenne quelques
boulettes avec sauce andalouse parce que
vous avez pas autant de choses en france
mais peut-être que je crois qu'ils
arrivent maintenant mais andalous sont
là mais on a que dans le commerce vrai
que toi me lapp a effectivement
andalouse brasil ma femme prendre asile
je connais pas son sens un peu sucré
enfin commencer la sauce algérienne et
la sauce samouraï qui est très célèbre
samouraï on connaît aussi un savoir mais
réagir l on connait pas mal j'ai rien je
crois que c'est un peu près comme ça moi
il me semble si je dis pas de bêtises
c'est un papa dessus et je crois que
c'est ok ok je sais que sur les sources
pour pour les sans but c'est important
alors j'étais en surpoids de pnl moi
j'aime bien pnl
qu'est ce qu'il ya tu connais le sud de
la belgique bah ouais je connais des jt
alors j'étais en internat au collège
saint paul de god in donc oui je connais
un petit peu la région
[Musique]
sauce dallas
je connais pas cette année c'est quoi
c'est j'écoute penser que c'est une
chose qui n'existait pas en fait il en
parle dans dikkenek mais en fait il
existe sept 7 cette sauce mais je savais
pas à tester l attester alors question
de me why wait ou 8 je sais pas comment
on dit tu penses quoi de la kpop
moi j'aime bien j'aime bien black black
commet
black pink je les aime bien
j'aime vraiment et je crois que j'ai je
crois que j'ai vraiment eu un accrochage
en c1 1 de leurs producteurs parce que
il ya plusieurs instructions vraiment
beaucoup et j'aime bien la façon dont
elles posent et tout donc moi j'aime
plutôt bien la kpop 1 c'est plutôt bien
foutu donc voilà
oussou 0,15 c'est quoi ton plat préféré
la préférée
je crois que c'est la bonne eau de ma
femme la bolognaise de mon épouse il
brise bah ouais surtout la bolognaise en
général familiale sur la meilleure qu'on
donc ouais ouais c'est celle de mon
épisode et mon épouse
alors ghostface tout quelle est ta
chanson sur laquelle la chanson sur
laquelle tu as pris le plus de plaisir à
faire là bizarrement poser cette
question m'est
donc
j'ai pris le plus de plaisir la plus
compliquée du couple about et mais est
ce que ce ne serait pas la même à la
whey je pensais la plus celle avec
laquelle j'ai eu le plus de plaisir
ouais je pense pas pas voter c'est vrai
bien vu bah ouais papa ou tél bah ouais
parce que j'étais assez satisfait de moi
même de la compo
et puis je me souviens que j'avais
chanté par pas voter sur un os d'une
autre compos et puis finalement je les
reprises sur cela bref ouais non non je
suis satisfait de faim pas mal de
plaisir par n'ont qu'à composer celle-là
est quelqu'un dans die die a dit j'ai
fait un exposé sur toi en musique et
j'ai eu 19 sur 20 ha ouais je pense que
c'est sûr tu as fait un très bon exposé
sur tout
voilà c'est donne en dehors
du coût modique aînés
l'amérique te plaît où tu es plutôt team
europe
ouais je sais pas franchement aller à
l'époque j'aurais dit l'europe sans
poser de questions et puis en fait
je me suis rendu compte que je
connaissais pas les états unis je les
connaissais que pas travers des films en
fait et je pense que c'est le cas de
beaucoup du genre dans le monde
on pense que l'amérique c'est des films
est en fait finalement quand on y va
ben on se rend compte on comprend que la
culture est différente fin évidemment il
ya fin d'amérique ça veut tout et rien
dire évidemment il y en a il ya de tout
à boire et à manger mais
ouais on tue il ya des choses il ya des
choses il ya des complexes qu'on a en
europe qui a pas aux etats unis le
rapport à l'argent par exemple le par
rapport à la réussite le rapport à
l'échec
toutes ces questions c'est je trouve des
c'est assez enrichissant d'aller là bas
parce que on voit l'échec aussi comme
comme une façon de voix la c1 c'est un
passage un peu obligé en fait et
finalement c'est ce à quoi ça ça fait du
bien de l'entendre parce que des fois en
europe c'est un peu mal vu quoi enfin
donc et puis aussi le fait de d'être
artiste d'avoir une marque de vêtements
de faire des choses un peu différentes
et variées c'est un truc qui est
beaucoup plus accepté là bas et
d'ailleurs quand on a lancé la marque de
vêtements avec mon épouse on s'est dit
il fallait être hyper prudent parce que
la mode en europe être très snob et donc
on a été hyper prudent avec ce a donc
[Musique]
ensuite du coup
chamia minouche est comment tu te vois
dans 20 ans
comment je me vois dans 20 ans bah j'en
sais rien
franchement bonne question
[Musique]
je sais pas si je ferai encore le même
métier bonne question je sais vraiment
pas
longtemps ouais c'est longtemps m 20 ans
il ya plein de trucs qui peuvent se
passer un
bon petit il aura 23 ans
moi j'en aurai
50,7 tu vois ah oui bah ouais moi aussi
c'est pas impressionnant mais
je pense que je serai sur un tabouret
déjà pour chanter
parce que allait faire décorer et
touchez pas s'il sera encore une bonne
idée
je sais pas franchement j'en sais rien
du tout on verra on verra que son destin
peut-être que je serai plus en belgique
j'en sais rien du tout j'en sais rien on
verra on verra a dit un prix
quel est mon morceau de mon préféré de
l'album lie l'icann no 94 65 lui dire je
voulais venir la vague non 24 65
quel est ton morceau préféré de l'album
je crois que c'est bonne journée mais
vous le connaissez pas mais en fait
c'est un morceau pour être pour le
décrire c'est un morceau un peu je
dirais trappe ou je chantonne un peu
avec des mélodies avec des voix qui font
un peu penser à à des chants amérindiens
et puis et puis des mélodies un peu
pentatonique voilà c'est une description
très tôt le matin
ouais donc donc voilà
alors à une grande artiste
mon livre préféré
[Musique]
ben je pense que c'est
je pense que c'est voilà je vais rester
sur le même site et je vous en ai déjà
parlé en plus à la sortie de leur racine
carrée mais c'est je crois que c'est la
zététique
donc comment s'affranchir du maître à
penser ou un truc du style de henry broc
c'est sur l'objectivité en six ans dans
le domaine des sciences sur tout mais en
fait tu peut l'appliquer aussi dans ta
vie de tous les jours quoi comment se
remettre en question comment remettre en
question ce que tu apprends ce que tu
entends dans les médias partout et c'est
assez bien foutu il y avait par exemple
fin c'est tout plein de l'espèce de côte
qui donne pour pour pour s'affranchir de
de
d2 de ce qu'on dit et garder certaines
espèces d'objectivité mais à cette
fameuse phrase qui dit on est en période
de électorale c'est assez intéressant
c'est que c'est pas parce que tu prouves
que j'ai tort que tu as forcément raison
et c'est une des phrases par exemple
qu'il est qu'il énumère dans son truc et
c'est intéressant en fait parce que
c'est vrai que dans beaucoup de débats à
la télé on voit toujours deux personnes
qui s'affrontent comme si c'était une
guerre de en fait je prouve que tu as
tort donc forcément j'ai raison alors
que ça prouve rien du tout ça juste
prouve que tu ideat a dit une bêtise
certes mais c'est pas pour ça que ton
argument est plus valorisées en fait tu
peux vous pouvez tous les deux avoir
tort en fait bref donc voilà bref c'est
un dur un peu intéressant quand même
j'ai faim et qui m'a appris beaucoup à
lire que couche assez cool ces courants
+1 franchement c'est 50 pages joliment
je déteste dire trop long donc voilà
écoute on va commencer à conclure je
pense qu'on peut finir avec une dernière
question yes up alors je passe celle ci
aussi bien que ses origines mais je n'en
ai déjà fait celle-là
[Musique]
kenan 18-12 est ce que tu pourrais
chanter pour ma mère le 14 février elle
est fan de toi écoute je veux pas te
mentir et 14 degrés moi je suis avec mon
épouse
quelques je chante pour ta maman mais en
tout cas merci est léger lembras très
très fort voilà merci beaucoup il
m'apprend qu'il demande dans live est-ce
qu'on est formidable parlant de du coup
à ce que ben oui bien sûr que vous êtes
formidables êtes géniaux merci d'être
tous là au taquet et j'entendis qaïda
mais qui étaient en cours avec qui donc
ouais merci beaucoup
donc voilà je vous remercie beaucoup
pour ce live
c'était intense et beaucoup de beaucoup
de questions que question je vous
remercie beaucoup
et je vous embrasse très très fort
[Musique]